dylan cease making his seventh start
era of 313 the record of 4-2 he's been
very good
so this is the guy that's the most
dangerous in the order power wise
jorge's solaire
doesn't go called strike three now that
one definitely was not a strike the
other two were
solaire better stop because he got the
benefit twice
in that sequence and then got punched
out on a real bad one
and now ryan o'hearn check swing that
time he went around
and that is strike three brady singer
with a five point
one six era is a switch hitter
a quick pick up there look at that
beautiful
very smooth so one away to alex gordon
who had a three-hit game last night
alex drives it to deep right field
and that is gone for his second home run
this year
against dylan cease and it's number four
on the season
hitting the ball on the inside fastball
inside part of the plate
at 95 plus exit velo i'm sure this is
more like a hundred but there's an
inside fastball
and he just knows exactly what to do
great level swing there
and he knew it two down for nikki lopez
two and two
he struck him out in the attic with a
fastball third strikeout
for dylan cease
the catcher batting first here in this
third inning
[Music]
strike three and the tag is down for the
fourth strikeout in nine batters for
dylan's season
solaire took a call third strike back in
the first inning it was
not a strike but the two pitches before
that were they were called balls so i
guess it all evened out
another one for him strike three he
blitzed him twice
strikeout number five for dylan cease
luis robert approaches he is in
the top 11 percent in all of baseball
and average exit velocity
on the ground past first base luis
robert
skewers one down the right field line
and as the sox first hit this afternoon
and robert ends up at third base one
down and nick madrigal returns
and a great opportunity to tie the game
up the middle and trickling through so
the infield comes in
madrigal in his first at bat in 25 days
ties the ball game three two
inside ball four tim was off he'll stop
at second and the sox have him loaded
for the hero from last night
so the base is full of white sox here is
grand all in a one-one game
and he struck him out with an elevated
fastball that is a
huge second out for singer the runners
do not advance
but now he faces probably right now
at this point in the season the guy who
is the leading candidate
for the american league most valuable
player award
jose abreu and he got him the leader in
rbis in 2020 in the american league
leaves the bases loaded the royals still
tied at one with the chicago white sox
lead off walk to eloy jimenez to bring
up edwin encarnacion
tie game 1-1 we're in the bottom of the
fourth inning
high fly ball left field gordon back at
the track shields his eyes it's gone
oh wall skimmer brings out the parrot
and
gives the sox their first lead today
it's three to one
that's a two run shot it breaks the tie
it's 3-1 white sox
left a slider up over the plate and he
finished it off did incarnation
as he blasts the white sox ahead now
three to one away to ryan o'hearn
swung on and belted high in the air deep
to center that's a way back
and that one's long gone ryan o'hearn's
second home run of the year
pulls the royals to within one it's now
three to two chicago
that's a beautiful swing he was ready
guy with two pitches now that's the
change up looked like there and
he was able to stick it 87 middle top of
the 7th one out
white sox leading the royals three to
two ryan mcbroom will
step to the plate birdie now brings the
next offering and mcbroom
skies this one in the air deep to left
field that's a way back and look at this
that broom has done it again
his third pinch hit home run this year
and
the game is tied at three
wow how about ryan mcbroom
going mcboom wasn't expecting it bertie
can bring it but he's going soft and
that's his spinner saying hit me and
there was a perfect
swing mcbroom goes boom
third time wow that's fantastic
what a lift royals have two on and two
out and ryan o'hearn is coming up
the runners go and ryan lines it to
right field and that is going to be down
for another base hit
with a runner in scoring position the
royals take the lead
4-3 on rbis from ryan mcbroom
and ryan o'hearn michael franco
1-2 pitch and that ball is
shot in the air high deep center field
leaping at the fence it's a goner
home run michael franco a three-run
blast and this
seventh inning has been absolutely
magnificent for the royals but there's
another fastball and birdie
just didn't have it tweet tweet he's got
to go
now you can tell sometimes that hitter
he'll sling his bat down
yeah that's well over his head on top he
got a glove on it they would see
looked like he was pretty close bertie
thought he had it
up not so fast young man that's the
fourth home run he's given up in
six and two thirds innings three hit
dave for tim
02 right side that is a fair ball base
hit down the right field line
fourth hit for tim anderson and a run
comes home on the rbi double it's nine
to four with one out
here is moncotta with two on and a
little dribbler out in front of the
mound is going to roll up the line
a run is going to score and that ball's
thrown away madrigal comes in
here comes anderson to score he will
slide in safely at second base as well
will wankata
two runs in and this is now a 9-6
game so the tying run remains on deck
and now it's abreu against jesse hahn
and what a great job by jesse hahn who
comes in and puts the fire out that's
his first major league save
and he comes in and strikes out grandahl
and abreu and the white sox give the
royals
a bit of a scare in the bottom of the
ninth inning but the royals
win it today